- Do you know why I lose all the time?
I only look for yes.
Heyyyyy.
You got your perspective.
(intensifying music)
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(camera shuttering)
Do you know why everyone's petrified
when I hire someone?
Because I'm just like, "You're hired."
(audience laughing)
Guys, I've hired thousands of people
over the last 20 years.
I've never looked at a resume.
(audience clapping)
Just...
D Rock, we have a very
small team where we curate
a lot of stuff that goes to Vayner
and he gets mad at me these days
'cause he OG now and he gets mad when
I hire these random kids and by the way,
I hire 'em from the street.
(audience laughing)
Just to let you know how
it actually goes down,
this is real.
You can go look at D Rock in the back.
This is real.
The last kid I hired,
I did it in the street.
Kid rolls up, I'm like
"You're fucking hired."
(audience laughing)
And D Rock's like "Fuck."
But then in my mind I
laugh because I'm like,
"D Rock, that's how you got hired, dick."
(audience laughing)
Abundance is real.
There's so much opportunity.
Please try to go into the yes business.
You're in the no business
because you grew up
in a pessimistic
environment whether it was
the neighborhood you grew up in,
your older sibling, most likely either
your father or mother.
You're in the business to say no.
Why not?
You're so scared to get
tricked by something
or look bad to others.
Your cynicism or no-ness
protects your insecurity.
The reason I say yes to everything
is because I don't give
a fuck what any person
in this room thinks about
my shortcomings or losses.
So much so I don't care
about what my wife,
kids, or parents think about
my shortcomings and losses.
The reason I'm so light as a feather
is I genuinely don't value
another human being's opinion
more than I value my own about myself
because I have all the context.
I know what my...
Do you know how easy it is
when your intent is good?
Do you know why I film everything?
I'm not scared of anything.
I have good intent.
Do you know why I don't
sell products or things?
Because I don't need to.
I make my money in different businesses
not that there's anything wrong with that.
Everybody can do whatever they want.
If you know that your
intent is good, it's easy.
I think about weird shit, guys.
I think about what if I hit somebody
when I was driving.
What if I killed somebody?
This is the shit that
goes through my head.
What if I'm driving and I kill somebody?
'Cause they jumped and
wasn't paying attention
or worst and this is why
I really stopped texting
and driving even a little bit.
I'm like what if that happened?
And it's crazy the way
I play chess in my head.
It would obviously change
the course of my life
and devastate me but it's incredible why
there's still this little voice in my head
that still makes it not okay
but boy, do I give a fuck about intent.
It's incredible how much
I navigate everything
based on intent.
I will let everything...
Right, D Rock?
We talked about the other
day about how I manage.
I don't get down on anybod...
I don't scream at...
If your intent is good, it's all okay.
If I don't think you're capable,
I'll fire you and try to
help you get another job
and I'm being dead serious.
I do it all the time.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But I'm unbelievably always
so passionate about intent.
If your intent is good,
you're good with me forever.
Period.
And so, there's just so much good
and opportunity right this minute
and the current mainstream media globally
is just talking about so much bad.
Bad sells in the short term.
Good always wins in the end.
(audience clapping and cheering)
It's just true.
I hate things like nice guys finish last.
Where?
It's just not true.
Nice guys might be losing at
halftime but they win the game.
Nice guys always win.
It's just so crazy all
this fodder in the system
that isn't true.
All the faking it til you make it.
As a fashion brand, that's agreed,
or at what every single
fucking 23 year old male
in the world is doing which
is fronting on Instagram
because boys want girls.
And so, I'm just unbelievably
passionate in trying to...
What I realized about myself was oh shit.
The reason I won and I'm good
is I've never played in the vortex.
I've never played in the
actual rules of life.
I was an F student when every immigrant
was supposed to be an A student
'cause education was the way out.
I launched an ecommerce
wine business in 1996.
That wasn't...
I have a fucking sneaker.
Thanks for wearing them.
I've always done things
that don't make sense.
I play outside of the actual game
and that has been where all
my happiness has come from
and so many things have
become obvious to me
by playing outside of the rules.
Playing outside of the rules is the best
and that's where I want
people to understand
we are pandering to so many things
that just aren't true.
They're just not true
and so my biggest thing
is the greatest gift ever
is actually having a life.
There's nothing anybody in this room
including myself will ever do
that's anywhere close to as remarkable
as actually being a human being.
The math is so absurd.
You're literally more likely
to get hit by lightning
23 times than be alive.
Your mom might've just got
up for another glass of wine.
(audience laughing)
Do you how understand how
ludicrously lucky you are?
You could've been a fucking tree.
(audience laughing)
What is very obvious to me is that
my perspective on life is
just fundamentally different
and now what I'm passionate about
is putting it out there
at scale free forever
and trying to change
people's perspective on this
because watching everybody
navigate right now
and do things and I watch it all the time.
You can't imagine how upset I am about
the current state of entrepreneurship.
The thing that put me on,
the thing that I've
always been my whole life.
Literally, that's right,
turn off the lights.
I'm pissed.
(audience laughing)
That was good. That was good work.
Go back.
The best part is somebody
probably just leaned on it
which I always think
that's the funniest shit.
Then they're like fucking
scared, like "Oh fuck."
Entrepreneurship right
now is so misbranded,
it's fun to watch because
there's nothing wrong
and I love that it got cool and listen.
Very few people have benefited more from
it becoming cool than me but it is not
the purity of what I love.
Right now everybody wants
to be an entrepreneur
which is very...
Do you know how hard it is to
be a successful entrepreneur?
The problem with entrepreneurship
is it's different than
sports and the arts.
If you suck at singing,
you get exposed immediately.
If you suck at sports, you
get exposed immediately.
On entrepreneurship, you put
it in your Instagram profile
and you get away with it for three years.
And so, I'm very, very
much passionate right now
to change people's perspective
and then after their
perspective is changed
and they actually are running a marathon
'cause they're gonna live for
40, 50, 70, 100 more years
and they have so much
more time than they think,
when they stop worrying about
other people's judgment,
literally the majority of this room...
Look, if you're at this conference
it is highly likely that
you're living your life
based on somebody else's opinion.
It's crazy.
It's super real.
I'm telling you it's super real.
You might not even
realize you're doing it.
It's almost like subconscious bias.
You're doing behaviors
based on the outward facade.
Do you know how many, again
and just it's a great time
for this 'cause it's happening.
Do you know how many of my fancy friends
have texted me and called
me in the last three weeks
about this whole garage sale thing?
They feel bad for me.
(audience laughing)
I'm being serious.
They're like, "What are you doing?"
My one friend was like...
This is just a funny text
and I laughed at it myself.
He was like, "Bro, eight
hours ago you were with
the president of Cuba and Eric Schmidt
in a super high level
discussion and this morning
you're buying teddy bears
off people's lawns."
And I wrote back, swag.
(audience laughing)
But, it's interesting for me to see people
see me from their eyes contextual.
It makes me realize oh
shit, they value the market,
they value the opinions of others.
They feel bad for me because they think
it's hurting my brand.
It's a very important thing to get around.
I'm gonna tell you why.
I'm gonna transition now tactically.
The reason I said all that is
here's the tactical thing
that I'd like to talk about.
If you are not producing
100 pieces of content
for Facebook, Instagram,
LinkedIn, YouTube, podcast,
every single day, you
are leaving the greatest
opportunity in the world on the table.
100.
That's a fuckload.
(audience laughing)
Let me tell you why.
If I said you had unlimited money
and you could go to
the beachfront property
all across this world and buy it all up
for a penny on the dollar,
112 years ago, would you do it?
The answer is yes.
The number one asset for this room
regardless of what you do,
you sell sneakers, you're
in the fitness industry,
you're a financial advisor,
you're in real estate, you sell doughnuts,
whatever you do, you're
trying to run for mayor,
you're trying to cure cancer.
The number one thing that
binds everybody in this room
is that we all need the
other person's attention
before we can tell them
what we want from them.
Attention is the singular asset.
It is the singular fucking asset
and right now the attention of the world
sits in mobile devices at scale.
And there's only seven or eight places
that we really consume content.
You have to figure out
how to send your message
to the world in written,
audio, and video content.
Now at first, you have to
pick what you're good at
before you can afford a huge team
that does what I do which
is convert all my video
into written form and audio and video.
At first, you have to rely
on can you do video yourself?
Are you a great writer?
Are you introverted and wanna do a podcast
'cause you don't like
seeing yourself on video.
I don't care but you
have to start talking.
I want to leave this conference
and get some people here to start posting
100 pieces of content a day.
Maybe 52 of those are just single tweets.
Maybe 26 of 'em are Instagram stories
but I'm serious and I'm
also quite knowledgeable
that most people here haven't posted
100 pieces of unique
quality content this year.
So imagine how fucked
I think you really are.
(audience laughing)
I mean it.
The opportunity is remarkable.
There is so much opportunity.
Everything that you're
seeing happen in society,
the people that are getting voted in,
the people that are
building big companies,
the celebrities that
are changing in society,
the people that are changing the world
with positive or negative impact.
Everything's playing out
in one place, the internet.
And the internet breaks
down into seven or 10
meaningful sites.
Right now the information
sits on LinkedIn,
YouTube, Facebook, Twitter, Instagram.
It's not super complicated.
What's complicated is getting good
at communicating on it.
It's a skill.
You have to respect the context.
You have to make 100 pieces of content.
Here's why.
You wanna sell a home?
You make one video.
Do you think that every
woman and every man in here
are gonna see it the same way?
Do you think a 22 year old woman
who makes 100,000 a year is gonna see it
the same way that a 49 year old woman
with two kids that makes 47,000 a year?
We have these platforms
that let us target people
at a specific level that we've
never seen before at scale.
Anything you wanna say to the world,
you should minimally say it 13 times
because you have to context
the audience that's seeing it.
You have to say, when
I do things globally,
when I make a video and I say,
"Hey Mexico, you need to
think about how you're doing
influencer marketing."
If I do that versus,
"Hey, you need to think
about how you're doing
influencer marketing."
And I post it to people in Mexico,
it disproportionately does better.
Not only do you have to
make 100 pieces of content,
you have to make 500 different
segmentations in media
and run it.
Here's the good news.
Everything I just said sounds hard as fuck
and tedious as shit, right?
But here's the secret.
Everything great should be hard.